hey g'day guys wayne perkins here just
uh come down to have a look at this
react pump it's down the bottom of new
zealand windham and southland
uh it's a ripper day but it always is
down in southland so um
gary got the chair going we sent it to
him um i think around about june uh he's
running mainly for the winter it's for
his
uh block up just got to pump water about
110 metres up the hill
uh for his cattle and so really just
needs it in the winter so it's not
running today
um so what he did he's got a four panel
system which is an 11 20 watt system
it's got them set up there across the
road so you can get good sun um
cable and come down he's dug the cable
under the road pumps down here
we've got about a two meter suction lift
from um
a good source down there and it's um
yeah it's been a good result pumping
hundred meters up two meter suction lift
four panel system giving a good good
quantities of water
uh the pump's going well we're really
proud of this pump and look if you're if
you're looking for something on your
farm if you
you need to push water up a hill and uh
you know
you've got no power around and you're
interested in some solar give us a call
you know the react pump
it's going pretty well there's some
people out there pretty happy with it
and i'd love to talk to you
cheers